hey guys the business 17th of January my
name is Jess and here's the biggest
things that are happening in gaming
today the sup GTA online has a new mode
and you car for you to roll around town
in and more weekly sales Elliott today
rock star revealed the new mode
collection time which is an adversary
mode where teams of two to four players
fight to steal and hold the most points
over a set period of time the points in
this case our money bags which are
dropped upon the death of a player and
become available to anyone to collect as
you've likely guest to the player with
the most points at the end of the round
wins there are seven new maps for
collection time and the mode is paying
out double GTA dollars and RP from now
until january thirty the new car is the
very pretty to watch inspector and
there's a bunch of other deals to keep
an eye out for as well as ways to get
yourself more money and RP which you can
read about more in our story on site
xbox one has a new dashboard guide and
here's what that looks like xboxes
director of program management Mike
Guevara brought up the redesigned guide
for a brief moment during a streaming
session the new menu slides in from the
left and allows users to save
screenshots or record video clips with
the press of a button it also lets you
easily access the xbox store the games
and apps section and the home screen the
menu also lists recent games and apps
and lower down the sidebar you can
access achievements friends messages and
settings among other features Gabara
previously said that in addition to what
you can see in this screenshot Microsoft
will add a new achievement tracking
overlay game score leaderboard a new
Cortana design and controls for
background music finally nintendo of
america president reggie fils-aime a has
explained why the switch won't time to
perform like the way you did while it
does have its fans the way you
dramatically undersold with only 13
million units shifted compared to the
100 million ways that sold Caesar may
has said Nintendo did not effectively
communicate the novelty of the wii u and
the clarity of the consumer proposition
was not
he also proposed that there was a lack
of strong games he explained Nintendo
switch if a home console you can play
anywhere with anyone clear compelling
where you will go down as having
fantastic content the issue was as you
look at the reality of exactly when the
games were launched there were large
gaps in between conversely feza may has
assured there will be a steady cadence
of content for the switch that said the
switch is arriving with what looks to be
only five launch titles so far while the
way you had 23 to this visa may has said
it's not all about launch day adding we
feel we have this great ongoing march of
content to motivate you to jump into the
platform be sure to leave me your
thoughts on today's stories head to
gamespot for news on destiny and
injustice too and I will catch you again
tomorrow